Yeah, for sure.
There's a lot of positive things that I learned from these two weeks.
Yeah, it was one of the worst matches I played today,...
...but also he was very aggressive and very fast...
...and I have to say I was a little bit nervous.
A little bit, first final and even semis, but very excited these two weeks.
I didn't expect anything, coming here before, I was injured and had little practice.
There are so many positive things for sure that I can have from these two weeks,...
...beating Stan and Novak again...
...and I'm very disappointed, of course, today, but a very good two weeks.
It's great to bring great news to Japan...
...and you know, tennis has not been the biggest sport in Japan.
Women's, yes, but men's never made this far.
So, I'm very happy to make history and great accomplishments...
...and hopefully, I can win next time and have something, more good results like this.
First of all, I played long three matches, played two five sets...
...and another three hours, I don't know, two hours, against Novak.
And now I'm here, my body's heavy still, but I am able to play.
I don't think, a few years ago, it didn't happen like this.
So, I think I showed my potential.
I can beat anybody now.
So, if I can keep training hard and also practice hard, I think I have more chances coming up.
I mean, beating top guys this week.
It's always fun to play here,...
...a lot of people, very loud.
It's always exciting to play here.